Now let's discuss some more details
of the various types of malware.
The first is trap doors.
Trap doors is also known as back doors.
It is a sequence of instructions
in the host program or system
that has been embedded by a programmer
and can be activated by the attacker.
Essentially, a trap door provides
a secret entry point to a program or
system, and this secret entry point
is typically known only to
the programmer and the attacker.
A backdoor in a program typically works
by recognizing some special input
command, such as a sequence of
input specifically crafted, or
a special user ID.
For example, an attacker can gain access
to a system through the back door
without providing the proper
user authentication.
A famous benign version of a trap
door sometimes called an easter egg
is the fly simulator in the 1997
version of the Microsoft Excel program.
The user when entering
undocumented series of commands,
can gain access to a flight simulator
program embedded within Microsoft Excel.